here we go all right let's try efore
let's try efore let's try Knight f3 the
chief this is an intimidating name I
have to say the chest chief man there's
certain names you kind of read them off
and you think to yourself they must know
what they're doing and the chief is one
of them maybe I just I like the name
chief just like I like the name the
assassin is the assassin here the
assassin 0 to 1 okay let's get down to
business here right Lopes I don't want
to go in for Berlin land oh that's a
castle watch over F to c3 tuck my bishop
back to c2 Bishop III welcome a dark
square bishop exchange I can open up the
F file if there's a dark square bishop
exchange let's go let's run forward with
it
if d5 I just reinforced this point with
bishop here I'm gonna come all the way
back maybe I shouldn't of no it's okay
just want to reinforce this point okay
no what does my knight go for that
little hike if I play rook e1 Knight g4
and then black kinda laughs at me I kind
of have to go back as I was saying
earlier maybe I should have maybe I
should follow through with Bishop III
welcome this exchange and then maybe
play on the F file I think I'll do that
I'm gonna take care mmm
okay is this not gonna play here or
should it really be a bother to me
should I force the situation no what's
what's my big fear h3 to stop night here
no I'm not afraid of night here in fact
if night here I take and then I just
kick them away yes to run away so I
think this is um I think I like this
move okay well I was saying I think I
like this because taking like this
really gives me some nice play and if
there's d5 and here we are we're seeing
d5 aren't we yes we are okay the chief
alright I'm gonna take and one thing
that has some of my concern is after if
I dunno I can't do this move right now
hang on and what should I do if I play
here I get forked so I need to defend
this pawn and also I'm defending by way
of this e1 square because I eventually
want to kick the night away with E for
and when I do that it's gonna play to f4
and I don't want it to come with tempo
that's the difference between one of the
differences at least between e 2 and E 1
additionally I might want to shoot out
along this diagonal now another thing is
that if I do this Knight f4 is hitting
this pawn twice I don't know if I'm a
big fan of that also maybe I should do D
5 D 4 with the threat of efore and then
pushing the pieces around the minor
pieces
whereas g3 worth the a closer look g3
I'd much rather not play g3
I'd rather not do g3 because of this
diagonal this bishops gonna be licking
his chops like he's gonna be licking his
chops what about d4 g3 I think it might
be important to keep this Knight out of
this square I think I have to do it is
weakening as it is I think it's
important to not allow this Knight to
jump in here probably gonna be seeing f5
but maybe there's some issue along this
diagonal probably not
if f5 it should be three there can
always be Knight a5 and then I have to
do something about that diagonal and by
the way my opponent better not be
listening to the stream and if you are
who knows the line that I use what do I
say if you're listening to the stream
what is it that I say the three words
you get hit with those three words s Oh
y-yes pyro frosty has been here before
as well as a few other ones oh man y'all
watch out I might be thrown these pop
quizzes out there every now and then
shame on you the shame on you you get
hit with the shame on you how dare you
that could be another one how dare you
listen okay
these are recorded and will be posted to
YouTube
okay now this bishop I like it being
reroute it's it's getting ready to go
here actually bishop here rook F to
Knight G for stuff that's a pain that's
what you call a giant pain but maybe I
could say King G - not so fast
I like the king G - not so fast idea if
my opponent insists I'm trying to get a
piece to h3 I might say I might go into
happy gilmore mode who knows what I'm
talking about there this is surely some
foreign language - some happy gilmore
mode if Queen here
what is my night gonna do he is not too
good he is not too good for his home
square
he might just come back I've had this I
think um actually in one of the first
game analysis videos I posted to my
channel I had I had yeah he's not too
good for his home
I had my opponent do this because I was
threatening to get like to h6 and it ran
home and it's difficult to crack at that
defense but anyhow I think it's useful
it's just clearing the way for my rook
it is defending against really the only
pressure that black might have the Queen
was looking to sink into h3 and follow
up with Knights
Knight to g4 and this Knight move should
I be afraid of it I can't move my bishop
my bishop is having to watch over a
silly pawn huh how do I make forward
progress to I just kicked this night
away I think I like that idea so what do
you do if you like that idea
tricky checks I have him all covered
he's got nothing his blacks intention
really to go back to h6 otherwise there
wasn't much progress made well if if
Knight h6 with that I can be playing g4
but there's probably some sac on that
square my queen could come up to g3 to
defend though if night h6 g4 okay maybe
I still want to do this or maybe I don't
the Queen e2 seems good rooks are
connected and and this was the first
thing I thought about stop the night
pivot from h5 this Knight can't really
do much and this Knight can't really do
much and this Queen I think is actually
not too happy about being the leader
along this battery on the D file in the
meantime less than one minute for the
chief to figure it all out for me a
minute and a half
okay my plan is to probably just do what
here just double maybe though I want to
stop this f5 advance g4 would buy me
some time and being able to double what
if my opponent is insisting on that move
though f5 if I do g4 I we can f4 this
was my primary reason several moves ago
to do g3 if I'm doing g4 I could forget
about controlling that square with a
pawn anymore for the rest of the game g4
g 6g 6 is saying you know what i insist
on getting this advance in I can do
bishop here but again night that night
a5 this night isn't doing anything if I
play to f3 this is still happening I
don't want it to happen I'm gonna try
this
g4 it is okay and they are insisting
they're saying you know what I'm coming
at you and I'm coming at you hard
alright now this Knight I think wants to
play
if f5 I could take like this and then
here working myself into a pin it looks
a little scary oh man I'm gonna do this
I'm down on time like we trade Queens
please uh who knew that one was coming
who knew that that one was coming
when in doubt trade those Queens the
chief is gonna come after you hard I'm
in a pin tricky Knights everywhere
tricky Knights the tricky Knight is
attacking can we trade a little bit all
I want to ever do is just trade all I
want to ever do is just trade where are
those Primo's get the Knights working
the chief is flying the chief is flying
trades trades I'm dropping upon no I'm
not I have a pawn Plus Bishop ending
pre-move anything get my pounds on dark
squares
he's a passed pawn and he's fast give a
check play here grab this pawn or not
eight seconds why am I not
thing sneak my king over sneak him over
Oh Oh King and pawn endgame just go fast
go fast four point six four point six on
time oh man ah man good game chief GG
that is definitely GG oh well let's go
back very good Rae Lopez classical
Bishop C to Bishop b7 is this a correct
idea something feels off to be perfectly
honest to be perfectly honest
what's wait a second
what did I say during this game I said
if you're listening to stream shame on
you I think I should be saying that of
myself for not just considering an
expansion in the center what's wrong
what is wrong here c3s let me back up
let me be more specific about what this
c3 move is doing ah not only Bishop c2
not only producing a square this this
Bishop can run away too should be 595
come trying to pick up that light square
bishop but it's just also expand in the
center why am I not considering it at
least I don't know if this is best but I
know that I didn't consider it and I
should have instead of Bishop III why
not that I can start kicking my opponent
around d4 bishop runs away d5 the night
runs away and then I do something else
then I'm not having to worry about black
crashing through with the d5 I think
that this is a something to definitely
have considered on my end and on my
opponent's end I like the Queen move and
I thought that this was okay actually
because of the follow-up d5 I think is
good and I don't stand better I really
don't see how I'm any better here
I play Queen over II play rook over
maybe f5 at its earliest point is best
maybe my opponent was afraid of Bishop
b3 but I think that the response 95 is
convenient hits that pinned piece
something to certainly be concerned with
if your opponent has an opportunity to
pin a piece that's unprotected it's
usually difficult to get out of but
there is a there is a reply thinking out
of Knight a5 so anyhow maybe maybe just
f5 right now and as a follow-up maybe
you can play your knight back to f6 and
your Knights are and good spots
classically developed and you get your
rook involved on one of those two and
there's no way I
I see mice there's no way I see the
white side any better yes I have a
majority a two-to-one majority in the
center but look at I mean they're just
so far back they're just on my third
rank be different if they're up a rank
not the situation here okay I think
that's my main point even f5 right here
again getting that in I mean it was
tried a little bit later but maybe at
its earliest point is the best point to
run with that okay are you trying to get
to these squares right here I am able to
defend however and maybe it starts to
become a bit more of a struggle now for
black to push forward with that I think
that this is still good oh and another
thing my opponent is typing that this is
their second time playing against me and
they had black both the time so they are
insisting that they play white okay
that's that's fun yeah
we could do that if I remember and I
think I will remember the chest chief
next time I play against the chief I
play as black okay yeah I think now
while we're basically and who cares
about the position and let's just move
fast without thinking type so this is my
main suggestion come middle game stage
consider for me my suggestion I have
first is for myself at least consider
deform it very well just be best and
secondly for black to run forward with
f5 right now it's early as point but at
the I mean the idea is that black ran
forward with have their have have clear
reasons behind them as well looking to
highlight the weaknesses that I left
behind a weakness of the last move g3
get 2 H 3 etc so very nice good game
chess chief